hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about
what is the link between cold and the
chances of getting fever and common cold
so people generally associate winter
time with flu season
but do you know the reason why in this
video it would be pretty clear so stay
tuned till the end of this video
and these kind of videos are dedicated
to public health and awareness
so please subscribe the channel and
don't forget to share this video in your
social media handles
many people associate cold weather with
common cold but the weather doesn't have
any
direct relationship or direct
correlation
for making people sick now
the viruses that can cause common cold
about which we are going to learn in a
moment they can persist
longer in a colder temperature also
they can spread easily when the
temperature is low
and that is one of the reason why these
viruses
are more prevalent in colder temperature
than the temperature when the
temperature is high
now exposure to cold temperature or dry
air can have adverse effect on your
immune system
in simple words it can weaken your
immune system such that your body
finds it hard to fight with the
pathogens
so overall cold temperature increase the
risk or make your body more susceptible
towards these viruses let's look at the
virus that generally cause common cold
so these virus include rhinoviruses
influenza para influenza or even
coronaviruses
now these coronavirus is not the kovid
19.
now most people generally recover from
flu within a span of 10 days so it's not
a big deal
even children and people who are younger
than
6 years they are more susceptible
towards
these viruses on an average everybody
gets flu for twice or thrice in a year
so rhinoviruses can spread via surfaces
in forms of droplets so it's a droplet
infection as well
researchers have shown that rhinoviruses
may
replicate more efficiently when the
temperature is
lower than 37 degree centigrade remember
that 37 degree centigrade is our body
temperature
now this is
a heat map of our body so in the summer
you see
majority of our body is pretty much
at 37 degree centigrade but when you are
outside
in winter season then many
portions of your body such as your hands
palms toes some portion of your face
there might be a temperature drop
and that would increase your
susceptibility
towards the virus especially
the temperature inside the nasal cavity
falls as low as
33 degree centigrade where the overall
body temperature should be
37 degree centigrade and it makes
a ideal breeding ground for these
rhinoviruses
now it makes sense why lower temperature
makes us more susceptible towards these
viruses
now recent researches have shown that
with lowering of temperature there is a
increased correlation
of occurrence of these kind of viral
infection
these researchers monitored several
patients about 1000 patients
throughout an year or more and they have
noticed
the occurrence of fever or fever like
symptoms
are more restricted towards the cold
month such as
november to february here
red represent the humidity level so
humidity level drops during this winter
it makes the air more dry
and blue curve shows the temperature
so the temperature and humidity both are
low
when there is an increased infection so
this correlation nicely tells us that
winter season
makes us more susceptible towards
infection
one study also suggests that
the temperature has a nice correlation
with the efficiency of
viral transmission at five degree
transfer
five degree centigrade temperature
influenza virus
transmit more efficiently than other
temperatures
now there are many reasons why
we are more susceptible in the winter
one of that
reason is reduced vitamin d level
now in summer season we are bathing in
the sun and lot of sunlight
is falling on our skin that is helping
our body to synthesize
vitamin d but in winter when we
generally
stay indoors we are not exposed to sun
that often that reduces the
vitamin d level if you are not taking
any supplements
and vitamin d has immune modulatory role
so it is making our immunity
weaker in general
sunlight is really crucial for making
the active form of
vitamin d which has immune modulatory
role
moreover in the winter season we
generally spend time with our families
and spend time
indoors so that kind of enhances the
chance of
the transmission of virus that means if
one member of the family is infected
with the virus
it is more likely that other members
would also get infected
lower temperatures may also affect the
way cell
respond to viral infections now
it has been seen in mouse models these
cold viruses
lead to infection in the nasal epithelia
now generally nasal epithelia secretes
molecules like
interferons interferons are alarming
molecule
which allows other cells in the near
vicinity to get
well prepared for viral combat but it
has been seen after cold exposure
the interferon gamma level has decreased
so these cells are not
really sending out those alarming signal
and not really helping out the neighbors
to prepare better for viral infection so
that is one of the reason
for which cold can reduce our
immune function
now in colder climate
the blood vessels inside our nose
uh are con constricted generally when
there is an infection
our immune cells travel
travel through these blood vessels and
they can
move their way out from these blood
vessels and
fight the pathogens but in the colder
climate
what happens is the blood vessels
actually get
constricted so due to this
vasoconstriction
immune cells find it difficult to move
out
and go to the site of infection so this
is one of the way why we are more
susceptible in colder climate than a
hotter climate
lastly the treatment of these kind of
flu
involves antibiotics which might bring
down the temperature
and make you feel better but the overall
thing is
you just need to relax stay
stay stress free and drink a hot cup of
coffee and allow your body to fight back
and that is how you get over the fever
but
do not ignore your fevers in symptoms it
could be kovid19 as well
so it's always advisable to consult your
doctor
immediately you might as well get
yourself tested
to nullify the possibility you are not
having a covid19
while common flu is pretty much
prevalent
kovid19 these days is also a big problem
and the treatment is better if you are
diagnosed earlier so
in this video we were supposed to learn
what is the link between common cold
and cold climate and at the end of this
video
we now know it so i hope you enjoyed
this video
if you like this video give it a big
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe
you can support my channel in patreon
and you can also take my unacademic
courses
using code ap 10 you can get 10 percent
discount
and if you are an indian viewer you can
support my channel
by scanning this qr code with vm upi app
thank you guys thanks for listening do
let me know in the comment how you like
my video